les établissements scolaires sont fermés
depuis lundi c'était l'une des mesures
annoncées par emmanuel macron lors de sa
première allocution présidentielle
gérard contacté à ce sujet sacha
bourguet c'est un lycéen de montigny le
bretonneux
on l'avait déjà reçu en plateau parce
qu'il est très engagé pour la défense de
l'environnement
il a monté l'antenne locale de yodok
limite le mouvement inspiré de greta
sonberg
et bien justement il était en train de
créer un outil collaboratif pour
permettre l'entrée ados sein de son
établissement
et pourquoi pas ensuite le mettre à
disposition à plus grande échelle
on l'appelle sur skype concrètement ça
ressemble à quoi
c'est un serveur où il ya différents
chanel de discussions qui sont
classifiés selon les sujets sont
globalement sur le serveur il ya deux
grandes vagues cia les services et le
matériel plus est par exemple pour les
services il y a une sous discussions
pour chaque matière comme ça on peut
poster directement si on a besoin de
cours de maths directement sur le
channel mat
finalement ce confinement pour soi c'est
la période idéale pour élaborer son
projet bah oui pour élaborer pas mal de
projets puisqu'il en a eu quand même
plus de temps même si on continue de
travailler que en période de cours il ya
tous les trajets par exemple pour aller
au lycée qui sent moins réputés
activités côté le sport ça pareil y'a
pas de trajet ont fait tous chez nous tu
qu on a pas mal de temps objectif c'est
presque après de le proposer aux villes
qui m'avait dit oui pour moi dans
l'idéal il faudrait que dans chaque
ville il y en a 10 ans a par quartier ça
m'aide et réduire la consommation
balladur les déchets aussi parce que
quand j'utilise plus quelque chose chez
l'occasion de le donner à toute personne
et enfin sacrée de la convivialité
évidemment puisque si on doit en fait
des services secrets d'une herbe donc
s'échanger des outils proposés du
soutien sur certains cours ou recyclés
autant d'actions possibles avec l'outil
préparé par sacha
celui ci devrait être disponible à la
fin de confinement histoire de
poursuivre cet élan de solidarité et
d'entraidé yvelinois